what's up Tom hey what's going on rich
that's a good point
[Laughter]
all right let's get right into it
what happened Malcolm Butler Tom best
you can tell you know I'm just writing a
column I'll give you a quick preview
this is the ultimate in Bill We Trust
moment Patriots fans adhere to that and
say you know what deference you know
bill knows what's best for the team and
that's what he says but you know that
sliding scale of appropriateness you
know you can tolerate a level of things
but if as Ian Rapoport reported it was
and he didn't even really say whether
the miss flight was excused or not or
the poor practice or it was a minor
curfew violation does that all rise to
the level of basically capital
punishment on the football field and
that's why I continue to wonder rich if
if there's something else out there or
if there soft-pedaling what his
infractions were so as not to smear the
kid going out I mean you you know this
town you know what the Red Sox have done
to Terry Francona assorted other players
when they leave I think that's very much
in the Patriots mind look he did
something we're not going to kill him on
the way out the door but there was no
way we were led into play well you know
in terms of that altruistic aspect of it
I hope that's what it is you know in a
way because if it was such a flagrant
violation of the do your job rules right
a flagrant violation of the Patriot Way
then why not deactivate him entirely why
waste a roster spot why tell him last
second where he's either crying because
he's lost in the moment of the national
anthem or he's just been told he's
benched in the Super Bowl yeah I went
around I've gone around with that and I
have the only plausible and I'm not
saying this is the right thing to do but
the only plausible explanation that I
can muster is if they had decided
earlier in the day and because I can't
imagine what he did after he was dressed
to piss everybody off but if if they had
decided earlier in the day and they were
going to make him inactive and would
that have been such a drastic
distraction
for his secondary teammates to be able
to dwell on it for an hour and a half
and worry about it and perseverate on it
and perhaps cause an insurrection that
it would have been a greater problem but
isn't it worse to do it in real time so
they're there wondering that or having
those feelings during the second quarter
as opposed to getting over it before
running out of a tunnel yeah all right
two ways for me I could say and I'm only
just trying to say what I could see
Belichick doing look I'm not gonna sit
there I'm gonna have a whole bunch of
conversations and arguing and screaming
matches with other guys in the secondary
about how Malcolm's getting screwed this
is my decision they don't know what to
know about it told the captain to
seemingly he told Durant Harmon Devin
McCourty
but guys like Eric Rowe didn't find out
until the last second so that is my I'm
not saying that's the right thing to do
I don't think the right thing to do
unless you know I don't know if it was
the right thing to do to sit him down
at all but again I continue to give a
sliver of the benefit of the doubt
because you know I don't want to be out
there with torches and pitchforks and
find out later there were a litany of
things that were sure beyond the pale
yeah Tom Karan here on the Rich Eisen
show I said it earlier in the show when
we were just having a conversation
also when Peter was a Peter King was on
here too is it that the ultimate boiling
down of this conversation is the fact
that we're questioning Bill Belichick's
coaching practices and he's the greatest
of all time so let's try and put it
somewhat in perspective as well how did
it matter how did Butler sitting
manifest itself in this game can you
point to anything
yeah the domino effect I mean he's a
terrific tackler he's one of the best
tacklers there is on that team probably
in the league at that position Patriots
a terrific tack was Johnson Bantam Ossie
was on the field for one Nelson a galore
and I'm not sure if you know Butler
would have matched up with him but that
was a third down play that went from a
loss to a 13-yard gain you know Butler
had his problems this year where he
would lose contact with receivers but I
think that Eric grow was beaten from
Jump Street on the first else on Jeffery
touchdown and was non-competitive you
know there was a
that we're out there turned into a
55-yard game which i think is the
biggest play of the game right before
the half which led to the touchdown that
was Jordan Richards who's a very below
average safety on the field again I
don't know if it would have been a
safety out there still but the domino
effect of having buckler out there means
somebody would have been on the
sidelines and you know it just it hurt
them and I imagine that it started to
once the the water started coming
downhill they must have been saying what
are we doing can't we have this player
out here and nothing I don't want any of
this if you're an Eagles fan out there
you listen to this should not diminish
what the Eagles did because they had a
incredible game plan and their execution
and the balls that they pulled in there
was some balls rich in coverage that I
saw them haul in especially the Jeffery
over-the-shoulder Massa it was a distal
body I mean what a key even the Corey
Clement touchdown debatable what the
throws were great the FL was terrific
Tom Curren here on the Rich Eisen show
okay Tom so when the Kraft Brady
Belichick meeting goes down if each of
them show up with a piece of paper with
an agenda with bullet points on it what
will Brady's piece of paper read bullet
point agenda for that Tom piece you know
I I think that he he bristles at the
idea of the tension and uncertainty that
occurred this year you know I had a lot
of people close to him over the last few
weeks you know I remember after the AFC
Championship game I was talking to some
folks know who were close to him I said
oh the hell of a performance you know
it's can you believe you're going back
so it's been a tough year it's been a
very very very hard year and we're
talking about a 2017 that they're
calling a hard year after 2016 had a
suspension and an illness for his mom so
they want I think that Tom Brady wants
it to be look let's all pull our oars in
the same direction
here let's not kick rocks about the fact
that who's not here ie Jimmy Garoppolo
about what the plan is anything else and
maybe Josh McDaniels going elsewhere and
we'll get everybody pulling in the same
direction again not that Josh was a
source of any attention but they're
gonna have to work their asses off to
get back to where they were and reboot
so what was what's on Bella checks
agenda what's his bullet points going
into that meeting yeah I think it would
be you know I'm the boss this is how
we're gonna do things and let's stop
with the via field agendas and let's
stop with marketing ourselves and let's
let's you start pulling our oars in the
same direction as well and obviously
crafts bullet point is going to be make
sure everybody stays together
but based on these bullet points where
you're saying peace and love and
understanding you know is Alex Guerrero
that guy that's in between all three
okay no it's the Tom after 18 years of
not doing much at all poked his head up
and marketed himself a little bit
meanwhile in doing that and in playing
the way that he did it kind of are
pooling their plans with Jimmy Garoppolo
and they didn't know what to do
hence a kind of panic we gotta get rid
of them get something for him now move
at the deadline and then additionally
you know the if if I'm gonna trade Jimmy
well then you're gonna be my quarterback
and we're gonna do things you know the
patriot way my way and that means if you
want to go see Alex Guerrero you go up
to his office Tom and then a little
mattering of an argument over that and
okay you can see him here but everybody
else has to go up there including Gronk
who is wearing by him now as far as a
guy who's changed his football outlook
and meanwhile Kronk is going to the
strength and conditioning coach and
saying
I don't want to do those things because
alex says that they are not good for me
so all that crap together what's
interesting though is you mentioned
Robert Kraft and I think that there had
to be a feeling on Sunday he's been a
fan he understands that Bill I mean bill
makes decisions that are outside the box
he had to go to Jonathan after the
Garoppolo trade was presented to him and
say is this something we want to do I
would imagine he probably had the same
reaction at some juncture on Sunday
regarding Malcolm so I wouldn't be
stunned if he wants to go back in and
his agenda says let's get a reset on
who's making on whose team it is because
I think that there's a conflict there
that is either simmering or going on you
know Robert Kraft said last week when it
was stated to him about Mexico City that
Robert goes on and says how great a
visit it was and everything and then
someone said well Bill Belichick didn't
like it Robert says plainly I own the
team we like it we'll be going back and
I think there's a fair amount of that
it's kind of a MacArthur Truman battle
going on who's army is it a couple quick
hitters for you Tom Curran before we
part ways Gronk Z play again what do you
think what was that all about
yes play again my feeling is it's more
about leveraging a more equitable
contract but I think that Berry Church
hit is swimming around in his head still
a little bit and he's like wow that was
a bad one
so keep an eye out and do the Patriots
draft to cubing do they yes they do okay
all right one or day two I don't know
but it's good it's not going to be late
day one huh boy that would light up our
set man well from a you know Malkin and
Belichick go back to the fact that
Belichick was his first visit but he was
his special teams coach when he showed
up and the Parcells Giants and last one
for you Tom you would probably give me a
good indication here this is apropos of
nothing just a conversation my guy
Brockman and I have had
Matt Patricia when he shows up at his
first press conference for the Detroit
lines as the head coach is he fully
clean-shaven
what does he know that thing that
thing's gonna be trimmed down a little
bit don't know so I guess that's option
three situation yeah you think so or I
don't know that's working for the
matriarch of the Ford family and he's in
the mid what I mean he's gonna he's got
it he's got to come clean right shave
that whole thing off don't you think I
mean I saw a turret poked its head out
of that thing please clean it up so
there's no insight you don't know you
don't think he's gonna he's a he's an H
see now in the NFL you seen what I was
saying to Matt Patricia is can you
explain this to me because it's bizarre
he's what he started 17 games for you so
we didn't get to the beard did you
what'd he say to you what do you say we
had a lot of packages and obviously you
know trying to get the packages on and
they're not amazing he's going out the
door to Detroit he could I mean come on
he it's amazing they all are the
Belichick way even when they're gonna
not work for Belichick anymore I guess
he didn't want to put on the Mangini pay
no mind list I guess right to the end
that will be that is the that is the
case study and how not to do it as you
leave Wow Tom love our chats as always
we'll hope to see it be come on let me
prattle on there you gotta know it's
great thanks Tom you got it that's Tom
Curren the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience